Film Courage: Shaun, can you tell us about the day
that you told your parents that you were moving
to Los Angeles and what were the emotions
that were going through you at that time?
Shaun Paul Piccinino, Filmmaker:
That's interesting because
I had been talking about moving to southern
california for a while and I had a very
close friend of mine who we had similar dreams
similar aspirations and actually in a lot of ways
it was him pushing me to follow my dreams
and chase my dreams his name is Josh Taylor
and he was a incredibly gifted actor comedian also
musician singer the whole nine he was just one of
those people that anything he put his energy into
he excelled and we had a english class together
in junior high I think is where it first started
and that teacher mr young was his name was amazing
he would give josh like 10 minutes at the end
of class to basically do a stand-up routine
and he really recognized that energy and josh
pulled me into being a part of it and so that's
kind of how I started really kind of thinking
about it past I i grew up in the theater with
my father being a drummer professor all that so
I was in the theater world I was very comfortable
but this kind of going up just almost stand up
in a way improv was was a little bit newer to me
at the time but he kind of really pushed me and
so over the years our kind of dream of moving
to Southern California Los Angeles pursuing
the dream of being actors really at that time
and what ended up happening is he decided he
couldn't go and so I was kind of left last minute
going do I go or do I by myself and my parents
have always been super supportive and they knew
for years and years I don't remember the exact
moment I told them I was going to move down there
but it was just kind of common knowledge in my
hometown I was directing commercials and acting
in them sent from like 16 years to like 20 years
old I'd probably done like 30 commercials and so
the kind of creative endeavors were always
supported by both my my mom and dad they
they thought it was amazing they loved it and
they said you should you should pursue this so
just always support from them there was
never like any pushback or anything like that
and so it was just a matter of when I was gonna
go and I also did some live performance stuff
and I made it onto the news several times just
for those kinds of things and again even in those
conversations it was so what are you gonna do
where do you see yourself in the next couple years
it was gonna be down in los angeles pursuing my
dream of making movies it was always that kind of
thing so the exact moment I don't recall but all
those conversations with my parents were always
you've got to pursue it it's just in you there's
something that you have to express and and we
support that and so when my good friend decided
at that time he that wasn't the path for him
obviously I was a little scared and kind
of everything that I had planned was
was now in the open and both my parents
were like you got this you you you
have made this plan you should follow through
with it you should do it and and so I did it
was very emotional day the day I left that was
really emotional we helped me pack up a truck and
and with the trailer and kind of everything I
owned packed up in there and and ventured out on
on my own which just a week earlier I thought
was gonna be with me and my best friend and
but yeah I i did it no regrets and and I think
I've always been adventurous in that way like big
big life decisions met and
married my wife within one month
and we've done some buying from buying houses
to to just uprooting and moving we've done these
things she's very much spontaneous that way as
well and so we've we've kind of done a lot of big
life decisions we'll we'll spontaneously
make a choice and just go with it and
I think what we understand is that we're going to
have an adventure no matter what and that and I
that's kind of my mindset as well I'm like let's
just go for it let's see what happens and and
and luckily my parents were very supportive in
that way that's awesome do you still keep in touch
with josh so we reconnected years later and yes so
we still keep in touch full circle kind of coming
back he he lives in portland now and married has a
wonderful family kid and he still plays music and
and has a band and all of that so I was doing my
second feature and when we kind of reconnected
through social media it was one of those
things and and I said I've got this
sequence in this movie it's an action movie and it
is this guy trying to go the straight and narrow
so he's trying to do the right thing in life and
not be part of this criminal underworld and his
friends in the criminal underworld they're trying
to do this kind of heist thing without him and so
the in the movie it's cross-cut between him trying
to get a regular job and them going and trying
to shoot up this speakeasy and both scenes are
playing out they're cross-cutting with each other
and I just had this vision of josh singing this
song just hymn and acoustic guitar this kind of
slow melodic thing that I knew he could do
really well from way back when we were kids
and so when we reconnected I went ah I've got this
I'm doing this movie and and would you be willing
to do an original song for it and so that kind of
full circle friendship came back and and he did
and the song is awesome the very first version he
sent me it was it he was like tell me if you want
changes you want no know of course I told him the
story I told him what was going on and he wrote
the lyrics that kind of matched with it and but
the very first version he sent me I just it was
it I was like nope I don't need anything else this
is what's going to go in the movie and it did and
and and everybody loved that scene that was like
the scene people talked about in the movie so that
was a really cool thing to be able to reconnect
with him and and I hope to do some more in the
future to get him to do some music for them would
be amazing very cool did you almost not drive down
since since your sort of partner in crime your
your your friend that sounds like you looked up
to him too a lot decided that he didn't want
to go I think that there was definitely that
moment I think there was definitely that moment
of of self-doubt or could I do this on my own
especially because it kind of had been this joint
dream of ours but again I think I had support from
my family and all that that but sure I definitely
had that moment and felt that way but ultimately
I think through the experiences in my life the
family support also martial arts training I
trained martial art from very very young I think
that probably gave me the confidence to overcome
any of those doubts and but yeah definitely had it
definitely was there definitely questioning that
whether or not to do it so you're driving down the
five of course obeying the speed limit I'm sure
right what that big old trailer I was probably
going slower than the speed limit okay and the
grapevine was scary I'm not even gonna lie the
great line coming over that hill in that it was
a it was a old chevy s10 it was four-cylinder it
was gutless and then having this big old trailer
pulling behind was that was very interesting
right and then you see the part where it's
like if your brakes fail you can go up this thing
you're like why are you telling me that yeah yeah
Shaun if someone were to tell you
that filmmaking is a pipe dream
what would you tell them I've always been a
believer in and again my parents have probably
get all the credit for this but you can
accomplish anything you set your mind to
so there's many things that can be a pipe dream
if you let them be a pipe dream but if it's really
in your core and your soul and your energy to
pursue being a filmmaker I think you have to
pursue it and that's really up to you if if you
are someone who has to express yourself that way
and I also come from that mindset and maybe
it's the martial arts but also families that
never give up never surrender type of attitude
so for me I have pursued this business in a I
think an interesting way I I've done just
about every job you can do in filmmaking
from hair and makeup to to stunt coordination
to I've always been and I had a mentor early on
in this business who told me to diversify or die
and I've really kind of took that to heart and as
long as I was working on a film or television
show I viewed it as number one educational
to the ultimate goal which is directing for myself
I viewed it as an education and I was getting to
be a part of something that I love which is
telling stories so I think pipe dreams are
only limited by your own drive and so again if
you don't give up I believe you can make it so
a lot of the people that I have been lucky
enough to collaborate with over the years
the stories are almost the same it's they didn't
give up and all these overnight successes you
you read or hear about they're usually
10 years 20 years in the making
and so it's those people that with that
drive that end up having success on
a multitude of different levels how many people
were in the town where you grew up roughly like
30 to 50 000 people is kind of the population when
I was when I was growing up it's probably more now
but it was also a college town so when college
students were in it it was like double and did
they have a film program there or not at the time
I don't know if they have a film there is a lot of
theater so like my father was a drama professor he
directed two plays a year he produced shakespeare
in the park so there was a lot of arts that way as
far as film goes I think you can study some film
at both chico state and and butte college but I
don't know if it's a full-blown film program at
least it wasn't when I grew up there maybe they do
have something like that now so did you ever drive
down or or fly down from chico to the la area and
see what it was like here I did so I still have
family who were down in southern california
both san diego some in in los angeles so
I did spend time and also my grandparents when
I was younger they still lived in chatsworth
so I spent time there for that and then also
I would come down for summers and visit family
I visited my family down in san diego from
probably like 14 through like 20. I would come
down every summer and stay with my aunt and uncle
and so yeah so I was very familiar with southern
california it wasn't wasn't a culture shock when I
moved down here in that way there was other things
that sure I i wasn't expecting but I at least had
some inclement inkling well I think moving to la
itself I think I didn't fully grasp what traffic
meant even living in san diego there's traffic but
when you live live in los angeles like really
fully understanding oh that it's five miles away
but that still means an hour in traffic like
that I think those kinds of things I couldn't
prepare for and I certainly think what I actually
thought was interesting is sometimes los angeles
might get a bad rap like oh everybody's so rude
or this or that I think I kind of had an opposite
experience like man people are actually really
nice and people say hello to me all the time and
like so almost I became a defender of los
angeles in that way I'm sure that there's rude
people everywhere and especially in traffic
that's when you get the rude people I think
but walking around the streets of of everywhere
I mean hollywood to to burbank to the valley I've
met such wonderful people and and created such
great friendships and so I think there's a lot of
misnomer I think same thing with new york you
hear that that new york people might have a chip
on their shoulder or something but again if you
go there and experience it and live there I think
you you'll find a lot of great people too sure
it seems like too that you can you kind of have
a way of fitting into any environment you go in I
get that sense that you you adapt I guess that's
probably true yeah I think I am very adaptable
and I try and find common ground with people and I
believe that's probably a a great tool to have if
you're going to be a collaborator so myself as a
director or somebody who's captain being the
captain of that ship I try and lead through
that idea of collaboration like we're
all working together for the same goal
I'm definitely not a it's my way or the highway
guy I i do have a strong vision and I do know what
I want but I'm open to all the different ideas
that can make that vision even better than maybe
what I was expecting so so I'm very open-minded
that way and I think that that open-mindedness
is what allows me to be adaptable and and
fit in and work in different situations and
I've just found it very useful I think obviously
given my parents and family credit but also the
martial arts angle of it I think the philosophy
of martial arts is is very much that way
studying something called tai chi it is all about
accepting energy and redirecting it versus trying
to like go head on blunt force trauma of something
it's more about accepting that energy redirect if
it's something negative you can let it just go
right by you if it's something useful you can
accept it and maybe redirect it in in the way that
you're approaching a problem-solving situation or
being creative knowing that you had this quote
unquote filmmaking dream and you you figured you
were definitely coming to la and this was going
to be your path what were the three obstacles the
biggest obstacles that held you back from maybe
initially achieving it or from yeah okay I think
i think some of the biggest obstacles were maybe
just kind of coming from that maybe smaller town
mentality like it growing up becoming a filmmaker
didn't even actually seem like a plausible dream
it just wasn't even something that I really
thought about it's like oh no you got to go
to college you got to get your got to get your
associate's degree like it just seemed like a
different path so as I started when I made that
leap and moved down to southern california I
didn't go right to la and so maybe there was part
of that just not fully believing it is really
possible I think part of me was like yes it's
possible and then other parts of me were like oh
that's just a how would you even do that how would
you even accomplish that so I think that that kind
of maybe self-doubt is definitely probably one of
the bigger obstacles I think just logistics like
like figuring out what am I going to do when I get
there like how how are you going to just pay rent
so that's probably some of it and then again
education I think taking those I took some
film history classes in in college and that really
opened my eyes and then also having a teacher
I took a creative writing class and then
discovered he also taught a script writing class
and so I ended up taking that as well so I
think some of that education also helped um
me decide that yes I could
pursue this in it at some level
and sorry didn't it's already interrupt but
you actually took the same class three times
so the the the history of film class that
was was taught at san marcos college down in
the san diego area was a great class so I took
the first class and it was alfred hitchcock
and so we went through the his film history
like from the very first film he did all
the way to the last film and we didn't watch
every film but we from the different eras we
he would pick a film and we'd watch it and so
we broke it down we studied the techniques we
the different things that they the filmmaker would
like to do and how they interacted with actors
like the full thing it was fascinating and I loved
it and at the end of the semester I asked him
do you do the same filmmaker every time he goes no
every semester is different like well who are you
doing next he's I'm going to do stanley kubrick
I'm like oh my god I've got to take this class
again so I did I ended up taking it three times
during my time there and studied three different
filmmakers and I didn't get credit at all on
the basically just auditing the class but I just
really wanted to learn about those filmmakers
and I think that was a really great education
and then it was a different teacher for
the creative writing and script writing but
I think after getting that education probably
helped boost my confidence and then I met and
married my wife and she was like why are we in san
diego and I had done a short film and she loved it
she was rooting in my corner she's like this
is amazing you've got to go we put in some
film festivals and did good with it but but it
was really her saying you can do all this from
san diego but why not go and try try it up there
and so we did we moved up there on a whim and
the rest is history I ended up
I was doing personal training
when I first moved to la to to pay the
bills but I got a job really quickly in in
production being a pa and doing all that stuff no
job was ever too small for me I was never afraid
of hardware I did extra work as well and I would
I would bring a notebook and painted I would take
notes and I would study and try and learn like
I viewed it as an opportunity to get on set and
see what it's all about learn the terms what do
they all mean what's that person's got to be in a
mark okay what what's minimal focus distance mean
I literally would would try and learn every aspect
of what was going on and again I felt I treated
it like I was getting paid to get an education
so so I had no problem I did I did
extra work for probably nine months
ended up getting my sag card through that and at
the same time I was personal training and then
I got the pa job on a tv show and self through
my own little short films and things like that
in commercials I had taught myself how to edit
on on on a mac one of the early like imovie and
final cut was first coming out and the whole adobe
suites were just starting out when I was was doing
that so I taught myself all the all the different
little tools from photoshop to after effects
to editing and so I had some of those skills for
my own short films and that pa job I did on a
television show of course I put on my resume I can
do final cut I can do after effects I can do that
and it wasn't even a week into that production
when they said hey we saw you do after effects
on on your resume like we were under some crazy
deadlines do you think you could help with some
rotoscoping I'm like oh yeah I've done that before
so they gave me a couple shots and I did them I
turned them in they're like oh this looks really
good you think you could do some more oh sure sure
yeah no problem so I think that attitude of always
just being there ready to help ready to work
helped me excel through through this business
like like wildfire so one week into being a
coffee runner on this tv show the very next
so I stayed they go what do you think you can
work on a saturday and help us no problem i'll
be there showed up help did did many different
things for visual effects not just rotoscoping
I ended up compositing some pieces I ended up
doing some like lighting effects and different
things in there by that monday I was a vfx
artist on the show then one week later I became
the lead green screen effects artist on the
show so just within two weeks just because I was
ready to go I was willing to put in the work and
just having that positive attitude
and also like when we first started
talking about this being able to kind
of blend in or or fit into any situation
having that flexibility is I think what helped
me excel and that happened on other shows as well
I was a assistant stunt coordinator on
a show and literally the third day of
filming I ended up becoming the second unit
director on that show oh wow and it literally
had to do with I think perception is also
being perceptive is also a handy tool I was
helping this the stunt coordinator helped with
casting all the stunt people for this show and
it was an action orientated show so we had to
choreograph and rehearse and do all these things
and I saw the executive producer pacing on
like day two back and forth frustrated and
just being just trying to be a nice guy just
hey are you okay he starts telling me about how
they're not making their days and they don't know
what to do and the director's moving too slow and
and I just threw out there just going hey well the
stunt coordinator and myself we're both directors
and I had actually already directed a feature
at that point and I said if you gave us a camera
we could more than likely help you guys film stuff
and and hopefully make your day I said whatever
scenes you want to give us whatever pieces you
want to give us I know we could handle it and the
very next day he showed up with a little like
skeleton camera crew and said Shaun all right
you're going to second unit direct this stuff
which at that point I got actually a little bit
terrified because I was now going over my
boss's head the stunt coordinator because
like the second unit director's almost the next
step up and so immediately went to him like
oh my gosh I told him that you and I are
both directors because we have both directed
that us as a team could help I didn't say that
I should be the director and and luckily he's a
great friend of mine I've probably done the most
work with him than anybody else in this business
noelle vega is his name a wonderful wonderful
friend and collaborator in this business for me
we've probably done over 100 projects
together because we've worked on video
games together we've worked on stunt stuff we
he's been a producer and I've been a director
on projects tel entire television series we've
done together so we've really done a lot of stuff
over the years and he just he's also one of
my mentors and kind of like that big brother
in this industry for myself but so I was mortified
in that situation going I by no means was trying
to go over your head or try and pass you up
and luckily he was like I'm so busy as the
stunt coordinator he's like you go do this you
go do it and he championed me for that and and
it worked out well because whatever I shot was
good enough for them I guess and so then I became
the second unit director for the whole series and
then ended up fully directing several episodes as
the season went on and into season two but that's
an important lesson it sounds like because you
learned to like go to him so it didn't seem like
you were trying to go behind his back yes that's
a very stereotypical thing that happens in this
industry and people do it all the time and yeah
yeah yeah I found out well at least it's been
my experience that loyalty in a positive way
obviously there could loyalty could in certain
situations maybe not be a great thing but sure
most situations is a good thing but but for myself
my personal experience loyalty has been a very
positive tool and I've only grown from those
loyalties and those friendships and those
I've never and I'm just not that person as well I
don't wanna ever betray or step on somebody to get
to get to that next level I'm much more the
person let's all build ourselves up together
we're stronger as a team and I love the whole
brat pack and the rat packs and that whole idea
like let's make our own film family and and grow
and and and do it that way versus I'm gonna climb
to the top and step on whoever I can to get there
I think in some ways it's a slower process right
not just stepping on people and
getting to the top as fast as you can
but obviously I think it's a more fulfilling
way to do it and I have stayed positive and
happy in this business I've been in it
now 20 years versus feeling jaded or
hate myself for the things that I've done what
I mean type of thing what was your first job
growing up like an after-school job oh my gosh
I don't know why it's coming to my it's like
I'm just seeing like you doing something and I
can't totally see what it is but I was so busy
yeah and I'm one of those people who likes doing a
lot of things at once like if you give me one task
it's probably way harder for me than if you give
me three tasks right so I think my first job
technically my very first job was teaching
martial arts oh really so that's what it was and
kind of I would I would teach a class here and
there as a teenager as a teenager and then I
went and got a job at taco bell and I worked at
taco bell because I really wanted to save up for
the honda civic hatchback nice so I was like 15
and a half and I started working at taco bell
and my martial arts master the the the head honcho
of the system the karate is a shorin ru karate
a very very traditional okinawan karate
he came through the drive-through
and he saw me there and he's like why are you
working here and I go what do you mean why am I
working here I'm gonna I'm saving up for this car
and he goes but you could be working at the dojo
and I'm like I can he goes yeah i'll pay you to
teach classes like so I did so I i I did work
there for a little while longer but then I i went
to the to the school to the martial arts school
and I taught full-time for years and years but
I did have multiple jobs still I also worked in
a stereo store I also worked at a local baseball
like for the baseball seasons I would go and work
there so I always liked having a lot of jobs
and and then I also started directing those
commercials at that same period so yeah I had like
three or four jobs kind of always going on but but
martial arts I guess it was because I did teach
some classes so it's either martial arts or taco
bell toss-up between the two but those were the
first jobs what a great story so he when you went
to give him his order like he's like yeah i'll
have the numbers I was working the drive-through
and then okay great did you watch this yeah and
then and then you're like oh my gosh it's him okay
yeah well that's a great moment right yeah
it was it was pretty it was pretty funny and
and just the look on his face he's like no
come teach at the school so but what I think
working at taco bell also taught me a lot of
great lessons and sure people's skills yeah
all of those I think all those things
are important and and I have kids and
I want them to get they're going to have to earn
a car in the same way I did I had to I saved up
now my parents did help me with some I think they
paid for the insurance and stuff like that on the
car but I think there was something so fulfilling
about that experience and and earning something
like that I think it was 2700 at the time for the
car wow and I that took me six months at taco bell
and and several more months at teaching martial
arts to save up for it but I did and I just
I loved that car I mean that was because I earned
it it's the first like bigger item that I earned
so certainly something in the thousands of dollars
I'd bought I saved up and bought bikes and things
like that but never I think that's part of that
coming of age and oh yeah all that stuff so what
was the first song you blasted through the stereos
because did you get your stereo from the stereo
store of course oh you did of course and I had
a really big booming stereo it was ridiculous it
was absolutely ridiculous you go down to like
a cruise strip or a room of course of course
I'm trying to think of what it would have been at
the time I like smaller towns have that gorgeous
circles oh yeah especially downtown chico
it's definitely a cruise that's you do a
loop and and we would when I was 16 we would
do the loop we would circle several times and
and thought we were very cool with our ridiculous
stereos it's a rite of passage yeah yeah
everybody's definitely definitely felt like an 80s
version of american graffiti it was very much that
which is funny because I've shot several movies
in petaluma and that's american graffiti was was
shot some of it was shot there as well the whole
cruising the strip was shot in petaluma oh very
cool but yeah I'm trying to remember I i listen
to such a variety of music I also play music so
I play guitar and bass and mess around
on the drums and stuff so I've always
have such a respect for music kind of in all
genres so I honestly I maybe I don't listen
to as much country but there's still a lot
of country that I really view as amazingly
artistic and talented people performing it so
I will listen or maybe it's opera maybe I'm not
an opera guy every day on my stereo but there's
some amazing music and such amazing talent that
I have respect for it so I'm trying to think of
what everything from tom petty to oh nice might
have been a tom petty song I listened a lot
used to love the cars back then oh yeah yeah
I played a lot of that but then I'd play on the
opposite end of spectrum I would play you know
bob marley to zap and roger to frank zappa to like
I really I really was I kind of have a very broad
spectrum of music that I love eric clapton I was
like obsessed with eric clapton when I was 16.
nice that's kind of that's when I was really
getting into playing the guitar and stuff was
listening to everything he did so okay yeah
probably tom petty or something probably
free falling right okay probably blast in and
head out the window like ace ventura at the time
or something and the arm too yeah oh yeah totally
totally yeah when you first moved to los angeles
and started working whether it was a little side
job or in the industry did you work any jobs for
free were you willing to take unpaid work so
yes I did lots of pro bono work and just to get
experience or that kind of stuff again you have
to do it to a degree because of course you still
have to make sure you're doing something to earn
some kind of income to to pay rent and get some
food and all of that but yeah there was plenty of
times and I did it for years not every time but
something would come up like hey this is a unpaid
gig but we need we could use some help or anytime
I had the opportunity once I got a little bit of
stability with work I would still do those I don't
do it as much anymore just because I don't have
the time but if those windows of time do open up I
never have an issue with volunteering some time
to help somebody out but yeah in the beginning
there was a bunch of credit building stuff that
I was willing to do because again I would view it
as a like like I said an education I knew I was
going to learn something and I knew I was going
to meet some new people and those two things are
incredibly valuable especially in this business
you hear all the time it's who that's 100 true
that is what this business is it is who it's
the relationships you build it's not necessarily
the oh somebody's giving favoritism or whatever
I'm sure those things happen too but it is about
if you came and volunteered on somebody's shoot
and you did a great job helping them with whatever
it was when they have a paid job they're going to
call you too what I mean and that's that's how it
works and and those friendships and those and even
just business relationships have almost always
led to a paying job in some way shape or form and
I tell people all the time when they're asking
about getting into this business like what's the
what's the best thing I could do I said create
something just create doesn't even matter
what it is put some energy into it put some
creative energy and create something because
you're going to call some friends and see if
they're available they're going to ask some
people whatever however that's going to work
and you're going to create something now you
can show people something you've created and
at the same time you've now strengthened some
relationships or maybe met some new people
and that network starts building up of who
and and they now know what you do and it kind
of goes from there I've had people who I hadn't
worked with in six years call me up for a job
because whatever impression I made way back then
it somehow came around and I came up or they
saw me on social media posting something and
here's my new short film on youtube and they go I
remember him I worked with him on and so it's all
about that it's all about relationship building
so doing the free jobs to me it it's always
beneficial if you have the means to do it
obviously don't put yourself out on the
street because you're taking 20 free jobs
and you have no way to pay your bills but
within reason I say do it because you're going
to gain experience and you're also going to gain
relationships of those times that you worked
for free for credit for something on your
wheel whatever how much of that actually led
to paid work down the line I think that that
quite a few of them did and again I think it
has to do with how much energy you're willing
to put into something I never approached a free
job as like that's a free job I'm going to have
half ass this job I always approached it is I'm
going to do the best I can do work as hard as I
can to help the project be successful and I think
because of that mindset and attitude I made enough
an impression on people that that they wanted
to hire me for when they got the paying gig or
whatever what I mean so I think again I think
almost every one of those jobs I met and and
created a friendship or or working relationship
with at least a few people on each one of those
sets that then led to me getting called for
something else even it was low paying like hey
can you help out with this I enjoyed working
with you on that can you I'm really trying
to think of any of that that led kind of
that never got a phone call that way but um
i just I can't really think of one that didn't I
think they all kind of led in some way sometimes
it wasn't right away like I said but they
eventually almost all of them led to something
positive in that way and again it's I think just
chalking it up to to hard work not being afraid
of hard work luckily I think again my family my
parents ingrained that into me enough that I've
never been afraid to put that work in and and be
the last person on set and even as a director when
I can get away with it i'll help put stuff away
certain job union issues you can't do that but
if I am in that situation where I can I do now go
why is the director carrying c stands like because
we're all in this together what I mean obviously
it doesn't get to work out that way every time
but when it does I was overseas doing a project
and they didn't have the same rules so I was
there loading trucks with all of them and trying
not to get in the way because sometimes you can
get in their way like and now I'm making us go
slower because I don't know what I'm doing but
when it when it's appropriate then
I try and help out whenever I can
and I love your website in that you you not only
have great photos of you on set and things like
that but you you say here's who I've worked with
here's what I do and you really like break it
down and I was very impressed with how you did it
and you did you do it in a fun way where it's not
it's not like you're it's over the top I i was
very impressed with that I don't think I've seen
that before thank you yeah a lot of that credit
needs to go to actually my cousin jeremy dunn
who helped me build that website and he's really
great with that stuff and and and I felt so
just humbled that the the actors that I worked
with they gave such great quotes I was like oh
my gosh I don't know if I deserve this but they
they really were helpful in that way and and
I really really appreciated them putting the
time into even putting some of those responses
and but yeah it was always the goal to kind
of just make it presentable and like here's
here's what I do and and obviously the
goal is to make myself hirable and and
and kind of showcase some of the things that I
hopefully help me stand apart maybe from the pack
with with my experiences from from the action side
of things to the visual effects side of things
and I think that's also an important thing
to think about for any aspiring filmmakers is
is figuring out what you can do that helps
you stand apart or makes you at least
unique in some certain way because those little
things can help can help you maybe edge edge out
the competition for I've certainly had it where
not only the action side of things have helped get
me jobs but also the visual effects side and the
combination of both sometimes has has helped me
because i'll get hey we want you to
direct this because we know you're also
really good at action I've gotten that call a
bunch of times where instead of just hiring a
director who maybe doesn't have that experience
it's the combination of those experiences that
have helped get me the job or like with
visual effects I got a pretty big tv series
based on my experience with visual effects and
obviously directing they liked my directing good
that checked that box but now it's a it's a vfx
heavy show oh my gosh he's also a vfx consultant
like wow okay that checks another box he can work
directly with the visual effects artists and make
sure that they're shooting it correctly and so
that helps just edge me out so having those skills
for those things are what helps me in a lot of
situations to maybe get hired for a job but it
could be many a variety of of tool sets that
you have but it's it's I think important to
lean into those things and try and present
those things let make sure people know that
you can do those things like if you're somebody
who's amazing with horses or whatever that
could actually be a big skill I could help you
direct a movie about rodeos or what I mean like
so all those things are are kind of important
to help you stand out for for what you do what
I mean and without of course naming names what
was one of the worst grunt jobs you ever had
and how did you get through it because I get
the sense that you try to take a positive spin
with everything even if it's
not positive and I admire that
maybe just one that was so unbearable but somehow
you got through it and I don't know if you took
something with you in terms of learning something
or yeah always yeah always always learning I think
i mean I guess the grip work is it's a lot of
physical work so that was tough but it wasn't like
I didn't feel bad during the experience so that's
tough to say that I i had a great time but there's
been a there was a job where I was a second a.d
and just the conditions were so tough I think
that was the like below freezing temperatures
and then blazing hot in the day we're out in the
middle of the mojave desert so and I was asked
to be the first a.d on it but I kind of got
i don't know how to say it exactly but I just
got a bad feeling about the project so I tried
actually not to do it but I had some some other
friends who really wanted the job like want needed
the work and by me turning it down then I wouldn't
be able to get all of them on to the project
so I said look I'm not going to be the first id
because I just I smell a disaster coming basically
and I said look I will help you I said why don't
you to one of my friends I said how about you be
the first ad i'll be your second and i'll
help you with whatever you need help with
if you want to do it I said but I'm warning you
right now that we probably shouldn't do this
and it just had to do with the people
involved and and lack of experience and
the extreme conditions we are going to
be in so I knew that it was going to be
difficult in a way that shouldn't be difficult
and that's like in the way of like making sure
people are taken care of and all that and
sure enough we trying to survive the the
desert in that time that we were in the below
freezing temperatures and not having adequate
things like warming tents and stuff like that to
keep cast number one warm and we did end up some
people ended up getting hypothermia and yeah it
was bad it was bad but we made it through it so
but yeah there was that was a very very
interesting experience and of course I learned
a ton from that experience I learned chief among
them that what to accept and not accept because
we said yes to certain things that we should
not have said yes to because it ended up being
dangerous like physically dangerous for
some for for certain things so but but
again I don't regret the experience
because again what I learned from it
really really helped me literally
on I think it was two projects later
I'm like nope here's the life experience I
now have from this this is why I won't do this
and this is why I think you guys shouldn't do this
and they actually listen to me they go okay all
right fair enough blah blah blah so it actually
became a tool for myself on on another project
of having that experience and going look we had
two actresses that got hypothermia do you want it
oh no we don't okay well then this is what I
think you should do here's the steps I think
that we didn't take on this project that I think
should have been taken and so by doing that I had
that experience to draw from and if the actresses
were fine they they recovered and everything but
but yeah it was that was a difficult
one to get through probably the most
probably the most and I guess as a second idea
I don't know if that's really considered a grunt
job but that was the most difficult one I think
a producer gave you some advice that was pretty
lasting yeah so I i was a personal trainer at
the time and I was still I was doing short films
and and and all of that stuff I think I was
making my first feature which was a back alley
group of friends putting their credit cards
into the pot and just making a making a film
I think I was doing that at the time and I was
he was somebody who was very integral developing
the fast and furious franchise as well as the
the show 24. and he just happened to be one
of my clients and and we became friends from the
whole thing and he was gave me some great advice
and one of the things he he told me was number
one he said don't be a a-hole that was one of
the biggest rules so this business is so small
that if you're a jerk it's gonna come back around
so that was one of the first things he told
me he's like and he was very colorful in the
way he explained it but he's like that pa
that you're working with on set one week
a year later they might be producing
the show that you're working on
it's that that's the way this business
works so if you're a jerk to that extra
they might be the star of some show
in a year or two so you just never you
should never treat people poorly and especially
I mean that's just in life but especially in this
business because it is really so small you're
end up going to have to work with the same
people again most likely and the other thing he
told me was if I really wanted to pursue being a
creator a storyteller a filmmaker to never
be a no job is too small never be afraid of
of being the coffee runner or being the in charge
of extras or whatever it is and also to diversify
so the business was changing so
much at that time it was when
digital was just coming out it was kind of
taking over everything and even dvds and that
whole blu-ray everything that was the industry
was just shifting and shifting and shifting
so he told me to diversify or die those were his
exact words if you want to make it and survive
in this business diversify or die and I took that
to heart and that's why if you look up my credits
you'll see I've done so many different jobs
is because I basically adopted the attitude of
just not turning down a job so if I was offered a
job and I had the ability to do it and I had the
time to do it that I would do it and and
again it goes back to that viewing it as a
an education it's like oh I'm going to learn
about this and he also told me that same thing of
look if you learn what it is to be a grip and
if you learn what what it takes to be the the
art department if you learn those things it's
going to make you a better director because you'll
understand what it takes to do those jobs and
you'll understand what they're going through to
do those jobs in the same perspective it's a very
important for a director to be understand acting
because you'll then be able to understand the
process or understand that there is a process
with actors and be able to sympathize with them
or help enable them tell their truth in that role
same thing with editing as a director I think
it's so important to understand editing because
you understand what you're shooting there are
directors who are not editors but I think you
need to have a certain understanding of that
in order to be effective it helps you with
time management on set it helps you when you
have your scene you don't need to shoot four
more angles that you'll never use and be on the
cutting room floor because you have the scene
it's there you've got all the pieces you need so
those two things I already knew were important to
be a director but I didn't think about the other
stuff the the what is the gaffer doing what is the
grips doing what are the makeup and hair and kind
of learning all those different departments it's
only going to help you become a better director
is what he told me and and so I took that to heart
and I took every job I could take I did everything
I could do and and just felt like it was a
an education for me and and would just help me
be better at the job that I was trying to pursue
do you ever feel guilty turning down work
you mean now yeah my sense is that you're
eager and you love what you do that if an
opportunity comes up you almost feel bad
if you can't take it because maybe totally
committed to something else yes yes yeah for
sure and what's interesting and and topical right
now is that I had to back out of directing a film
overseas because of the pandemic and actually I
was over there when it started getting really bad
I was over there prepping and it's gonna be a
fantastic film I am now kind of jealous that I
didn't get to direct it but when this whole
thing first came up I started getting bad and and
was definitely really worried about getting
home because it became one of those things of
at the time they're like what you could just
stay a couple extra weeks and wait it out
and then when it's safe to travel again it was one
of those and but what what ended up happening was
the international flight started cancelling like
just stopping all international flights and I went
I think I'm going to have to go home because I
can't get stuck here I've got a family and all
that so I did I ended up getting home and on the
last weekend where those international flights
were flying I got home and did the quarantine did
all that stuff got tested and I was fine but the
it the whole thing got pushed because of
it and but then it came down to this thing
when they wanted to shoot it still was just
not a safe time to be to go and travel and
and the worry of being able to get home was
so just too big of a worry it was just too
much to to be able to commit and go there and
do it and I felt horrible turning that down
because I had committed to doing this project
with with these wonderful filmmakers and uh
some of which I had really dreamed
about working with for a long time
because they were a big part of asian cinema like
with with jetley and jackie chan and all that and
so I had to turn it down I felt so so bad but
obviously it's not under my control it was out
of my control the whole situation so but yeah
I think I do feel that way because I just enjoy
I enjoy creating and and helping tell stories
in in whatever the capacity whether it's even
if it's stunt coordinating that's still your part
of telling that story you're part of telling the
the story of the action of how it's happening and
unfolding and I just love I love that process so
and I think there's also that element of feeling
like you might be able to help somebody uh
and then not being able to having to say no I
can't help you because I get those those calls
fairly often it's it's somebody usually when
they're calling me because they need your piece
of expertise or something that you might be able
to be that puzzle piece for them and then when
you're not available obviously that's that sucks
but I always try and recommend somebody I'm like
call this person or I'm definitely that that way
as well I really love to to if I can't do it get
somebody else the work what I mean and so
I do that we're gonna break the fourth wall
here and we're gonna title this video how
to get four movies on Netflix in two years
now we just need you to give us the nuts
and bolts of how that happens and then we
can put that title on it okay so now
are you saying from start to finish
yeah what what so what are the four movies and
what are their genres maybe we'll start with that
okay sure sure so yeah I i was lucky
enough to get to direct and and work on
four films that have all been released in
this year 2020 on Netflix which is kind of
mind-boggling I was never planned that way I think
this year has brought a lot of curveballs and
a lot of people were looking for a lot of content
so it kind of worked out but the first movie I did
that was released on Netflix was roped and it's a
kind of coming of age a little bit of like a teen
romance some have described it as like a footloose
meets a western or something or a rodeo movie
and that was wonderful to work on and the two
leads of that are Josh and Lauren Swickard
at the time Lauren York but they actually met and
fell in love on the set it was a real life romance
going on at the same time that we were filming
that movie the second movie I did was lady driver
that was led by grace van dien and she's I think
a wonderful wonderful actress I think she's a
big big star in the making and
of course Shaun patrick flannery
was in that with her as well and also
her dad did a cameo casper van bean
and that's about a young woman who becomes a
race car champion or pursues becoming a race car
champion kind of in her it's kind of in her family
blood and so again it's a coming of age it's her
kind of figuring all that stuff out finding
out about her past that she didn't know about
and then after that was this really zany comedy
it's my first feature comedy I've love absolutely
adore comedy and even in action films I i try and
put in comedy I just love the opportunity and the
vehicle to try and make people smile in any which
way that I can so I'd done comedic commercials
in the past and I've done short films that are
that are comedy but never a feature so this was
my first feature comedy and I had an absolute
blast making it's probably the most fun I've
ever had on a set the actors and matt jones and
noreen dewolfe and maddie carderoppal and um
they're just we're so funny that in front of the
camera off the camera they're so funny that just
the whole experience was just absolutely hilarious
and john ducey who wrote it was also in it
he's hilarious and and his wife christina moore is
also in it so they're just all such a funny cast
along with Ali Afshar that that one's that
one's kind of I don't know if many people
will know this movie but there's a movie called
brewster's millions and it's the basically the
the nuts and bolts of it is estranged father
leaves his fortune and his will to to his his son
and in our movie the son he has two other siblings
who believe they should be the heirs to the
to the family fortune but on his deathbed the
father leaves a challenge for his his estranged
son to be able to get the family fortune if he
competes in these races across the country and
he has to podium it's totally not believable it's
totally over the top but basically he has to go
across the country and compete in different races
from motorcycle like motocross to drag drag boats
to monster trucks I mean like we did we went
across the gamut of the the racing world and
just had a blast with it and then the last one
is which just came out is California Christmas
and that's just a very sweet kind of rom-com
christmas movie and that again stars Josh and
Lauren Swickard and this time she wrote the script
Lauren Swickard wrote it and produced it and
along with Ali Afshar but it was a great reunion
with them both acting in it now married and
we became very again what we talked about earlier
about the relationships you build it really that's
exactly what this was all about we had a great
experience on one project and we're trying to
figure out what to do in the future when the time
was right what can we do again together and this
is the vehicle that came up for that and I jumped
at the chance as soon as I got called and said hey
do you want to direct another movie with Josh
and Lauren I'm like yes what is the well first
obviously I got to read the script but almost like
not even knowing the script it was already like a
yes like yes I want to do another film with them
because it was just such an enjoyable experience
and and this one it's the big city guy comes and
he's trying to buy the property from the from the
the ranch from the young woman who who owns the
ranch and so it's that kind of thing and he gets
dragged into doing work on the on the ranch and
of course they fall in love and it's that kind
of thing but there's some good little twists in
it and there's some really fun characters that
are unexpected in there and you've got david
del rio who's a really great comedic actor
just a great actor in general but he's
also really really good at comedy and
he's really funny in this movie so we had a lot
of fun with that and yeah they all all of them
ended up on Netflix this past year and or this
year and that was I felt just very blessed that
that is a reality that that happened wasn't
expecting it you're making these movies you
don't necessarily know when they're gonna come
out but yeah they they all did and so how does
that happen is that something where you knew up
front that you were making these to eventually
be on Netflix a distributor got them on the
producer had inroads yeah so the first three no
the first three we didn't know exactly what the
distribution path would be California Christmas
is a Netflix original so yes we did know from the
get-go on that one and there's that collaboration
so that was really exciting when we were doing it
too just knowing that we that that that's going to
be the home this is just a really and obviously
then there's the pressures of making sure you
do it right and do it justice and make them
happy and everything but the first three no we we
we made them with obviously Netflix
would be a a great place for them to
land so you shoot for those shoot for that
as a goal of course but obviously there's
amazon and there's hulu and there's there's
theatrical there's just going a traditional
route like itunes or whatever so there's
all sorts of different avenues you could go
but I definitely think Netflix was a goal
place to try and get them and luckily with
the relationships that the production team
and like our producers like Ali Afshar the
relationships he's built have helped us get us
into those doors and ultimately get find their
home there has has he had other movies on Netflix
did he already have a pre-existing relationship so
I think with roped the cut several of them
got released the same day so I think it was a
a kind of a little bit of a package deal there so
I'm not exactly sure if there was anything before
that that had made it onto Netflix I think those
were the first ones so no not necessarily but
relationships with with like we kind of have a
kind of loose partnership like sales partnership
with warner brothers so that relationship
was already established and so I think it
was through that relationship again some of this
stuff is above my pay grade but I do know that we
we have partnered especially on the sales ends
of things with warner brothers in the past
and so that has been kind of a a very good
relationship there with with several movies
and then when it came to this again I am not
100 sure but I think that was the the the
relationship that then bridged into Netflix so
so Ali has these relationships and is this from
I know he has a racing does something with racism
so yeah so yeah Ali ali is again now I've done
more movies with him than I've done with anybody
else so our partnership him producing me directing
I've done five films with him and obviously I keep
coming back because I love working with him and
again it's another really just great friendship
that has developed over the years and so
he started he's got a great story so he grew
up in northern california I also grew up in
northern california so there's a little bit of
that bond there but he got into racing kind of
in a roundabout way but I mean he was always into
racing but how he got sponsorships and everything
was him and his team his buddies they figured out
how to take a subaru and modify it in a way to be
obviously incredibly fast but compete in drag
racing and at that time subaru they're rally
racing and they did other things other kinds
of racing but came nowhere near drag racing but
the way how he was able to figure out
how to take I believe it's a six cylinder
and like drag race with these huge muscle cars and
wind was kind of revolutionary and especially for
for subaru themselves and so if I'm remembering
the story correctly they came out to meet him
and he took them in the car and showed him what
it could do and they wanted to sponsor him so he
traveled the world did all these races and and
got even more advanced with the subarus and took
them to like world record holding numbers
and he I believe he still holds some world
records with to his team and subaru with the drag
racing so he did really well for himself there
and through different sponsorship deals
that's how he met other sponsors who then
became hey why don't we make some movies
together would you want to make a movie
about race cars what I mean so it became that
that's how he kind of got into that whole world
and I think he had also just done some
acting on the side because that was another
passion of his I know he was on like king
of queens he kind of had a character who
would come back every so often and I know he
did some some of the stuff early on as well
I don't know where that overlaps with
him making movies and all of that but
he kind of tried to marry his two loves
I think which was racing and acting and
and and all of that so they ended up
making a couple race car movies first
okay and then that started bridge bridging out
from there started expanding into other stories to
tell not just racing but we do always kind of come
back to the racing too because that is obviously
a big passion of his so even like our comedy
wheels of fortune that I was describing earlier
it's obviously all the different race car elements
I mean from the motorcycles to the boats to the
off-road trucks to the it's we do find ways to do
do stories that also involve the racing right so
interesting so he has this sort of mindset of
of finding sponsors and and partnering what he
loves to do with these bigger companies he's
really good at that again he's really good at
those relationship building and and
that we talked about earlier he's uh
he's very personable very nice guy all of
those things and and and has great ideas and
has this incredible ambition and and I think his
energy is infectious that way as well so I think
he attracts those kinds of people that with
like-minded energy and want want to create
these things and so I think he's produced
it's really hard to keep track of them all I think
he's produced 16 movies and two television series
now and all within a matter of five years or
something like that or maybe even under that
so yeah when he sets his mind to those things
he's he really excels and then luckily I was
able to to partner with him and that was through
again it we talk about how work begets work right
so it was an actor named shane graham who's also
a wonderful actor I think he's a big star as well
and he's he's doing really great work he's got a
movie right now called ride which is on amazon and
that one's doing really really well and again
that's the same same filmmaker Ali Afshar is also
the producer of that so he had just finished
filming that when he came onto a tv series I
was directing and we became fast friends
and he said man I got to introduce you to
these other filmmakers and he in kind told them
you've got to meet this director Shaun I think
you guys would get along great so it's really him
helping bridge that relationship and then some of
the producers not Ali came to set and actually
the other director the other main director for
for ali's company esx entertainment alex rena
revello has directed I think he's directed like
at least ten movies with them I've done five he's
yeah yeah and so he he came to set he came to
visit it's almost like the the if if he approved
of me then they would take a meeting with me type
of thing and he was lovely and and he came to set
and visited when we were we were launching some
b-25 bomber it was a world war ii thing and
i'll be like perfect day for him to come see
we're doing some really cool stuff so he came and
visited and and luckily he reported back that that
I seemed like maybe a good match for them as
well so I went out to warner brothers and and
met up with Ali and and again I think we we hit
it off right away and I really liked the story
the the movie that they were talking to me about
directing at the time is called American Fighter
and that comes out in early early 2021 it's
it's finally coming out so that one's been
it's been a while since we first started that one
but it's finally coming out I believe in march
is when that one's going to come
out but so I met with them and
luckily they they liked me enough and and the rest
is history I then did four more movies after that
one with them and hopefully more knock on wood I
would love to do of course more projects with them
wow that's really fascinating so because I think
Ali when I read his bio I said he he was going to
med school and then he became he wanted to be an
actor instead and then the race car driving came
in there and then is that that's fascinating
then yeah and then yeah find the sponsorship
and that would take him back to acting exactly
yeah yeah yeah it's really it's really amazing and
he's a great producer that way I mean he he's he's
just one of those people that any problem even I
i view myself as a great problem solver but I even
run into certain issues that maybe I can't tackle
he comes in and it's and he fixes it I we were
shooting lady driver and it had just rained and
we're on this it's this really nasty kind of clay
that just will your cars will sink in it and all
that kind of stuff and you won't get them out like
it's one of those things so it had rained a couple
days before we were at this racetrack and we're
supposed to film everything in there in their race
pits and but the problem is it had rained a couple
days and the the the track the guy running the
track was like I don't think you can bring these
big heavy production trucks and vehicles on here
and he goes we'd have to bring in a tractor and
we'd have to like lay down like like till it up
and lay down some more stuff and blah blah
I'm like well where are we gonna film this
like this is here today is here's our schedule
this is what we're supposed to film on this day
and I kept talking to the guy going what can we do
where can we film it can we do it here or is there
any way to to make it work there can we bring the
tractor he goes no I don't think it can happen
then my producer my field producer comes in
he's talking to him nope can't happen nope
everybody nope can't happen here comes
Ali what's wrong what's going on I go
well because it rained here we can't get
the vehicles out there as well he goes
he goes okay hold on he goes two minutes he's
over there talking to the gentleman comes back
yeah we're gonna be able to film there go what
how did you make that happen he's just one of
those people that just makes those kinds
of things happen of course the guy got the
tractor he did all the work I don't know I don't
know what they said or what was talked about but
he was able to make that happen and we filmed the
whole day where we were supposed to film it and
and it all worked out and and yeah so very
interesting Shaun can you further explain how you
got the first two films on Netflix yeah so I think
the the first couple films that we got on there
had to do with the relationship with
warner brothers and them kind of being the
handling the sales of the films if that
makes sense so they're the ones who
and I say they I really again a lot
of this is above my pay grade but
I know it was a relationship with warner
brothers representing the films to sell them
and they sold it to Netflix so that's how they got
it on there and I believe it was a package deal
again it's above my pay grade but I believe
that's how the first couple of films got on there
and of course then the relationship builds
and then we got a couple more on there and
that went really well for us and then now we've
got the newest one California Christmas that just
came out so I think we have it's not just my
four films with the same company with esx and
ali's ally's company I think we now have seven
films on there on Netflix so it's been a the
relationship obviously through warner brothers
has built and it's been really really fantastic
and sorry how did you get the first relationship
going with warner brothers and I know that part's
not I have no you have no clue yeah that's that's
that's all Ali right that's his relationship so I
don't know how that all started right you've been
a director for hire on all four movies that have
gone to Netflix were you competing with other
directors at that time for the job I do know um
yes I think there's always been
other directors in consideration
a few of them know I think we just from the
get-go we knew that I was going to do it and
that's because we had already established
that relationship but yes there was other
I guess because American Fighter was the first
film I directed with them and there was other
directors being considered but that one hasn't
come out yet that one's not on Netflix yet that
one is released in again in march so that one I
knew I definitely was competing and there's always
there is also that alex arena rubella who has
directed a bunch of movies with them so it's like
are you gonna direct this when you're gonna direct
and we also have brett headland who has been the
editor on all of our films he also directed a
film for esx called the stand-up packs and county
which I helped develop that script but he
ended up directing it because I was directing
wheels of fortune so I think yeah there's those
things and and certain ones yes there's other
in consideration and then other ones it's
been hey we love what you do we want you
we think you could tell the story really well
and so I just get offered it but certainly in
the beginning there was definitely more of that
considering other directors for the projects
did you personally meet with anybody at Netflix
did you go to Netflix no you haven't okay no yeah
I haven't had any I have met with people from
Netflix before but not for these movies again
being the director I'm not the producers of them
I'm not I don't have I am very involved in the
post-production process from everything editing
visual effects sound design adr score I i have my
fingers in every single part of that but in making
sure that the deliverables get done but beyond
that like I said it's kind of above my pay grade
and I'm not involved on that level now if it'd be
something that I produced then that might be more
the case and I have had those conversations with
films that are I have personally produced that
are through my stuff but but I did have a movie
long ago on Netflix but it was when there were
still dvds that they would send to your house so
I remember those days yeah it's exciting to check
the mail how much involvement does Netflix have
during production I know you said with California
Christmas yeah this is our first this is our first
Netflix original so yeah there is a certain
involvement and again warner brothers
there are also those relationships there kind of
overseeing making sure everything's going good and
and all that I think because of when we filmed
this we were one of the first films after this
pandemic has started to come back and film there
was tv shows some docu-series that had been going
but we were one of the first film film productions
to go back in so I think there's because of those
reasons it's maybe a different experience than
it would have been prior to this so there's not
a whole bunch of people that just randomly come
into sets like everything is very small controlled
there was some zoom sessions in those kinds of
things from from more of the executives in that
regard but esx was in charge of producing the
product but yes from script levels to overseeing
sending clips sending data whatever it is their
involvement is that way but not coming to set and
and overseeing it in that respect at least not
on this again like I said I think because of
just the current world affairs that that it was
more from afar what I mean sure but so you were
sending them dailies I don't know those dailies or
like certain scenes cut together scenes here that
show you a sample those kinds of things but the
way that we do dailies now it's all digital it's
all up on there so again I'm not sure what sent
to who because I'm so razor focused on filming
and getting the stuff done but very likely it
could have been sent to them to review yeah and
they reviewed the script and gave you notes yes
yeah yeah all that stuff was of course they have
to have approval on all that kind of stuff Shaun
forgive me for asking this but the timeline can we
just go over that one more time for these movies
because it sounds like it's happened so fast yeah
this year has been very interesting again I think
I think because people are so starving for content
it's why so many of my projects came out but roped
in lady driver kind of came out at the same time
on Netflix and so those were already out then we
were already in development and and working on a
California Christmas before wheels of fortune
came out so we're actually on set filming a
California Christmas oh I'm sorry actually was
after a California Christmas stopped filming
when I was on a different television a different
project when wheels of fortune came out
and so yeah so it was had a couple of them on
there we I don't remember if that I think the deal
was in place when we started filming California
Christmas four wheels a fortune to come out but it
didn't come out until after we were done filming
it and then the California Christmas is the one
we had the clearest like date of when where it
was going to release because it's holiday movie
we knew december they wanted it to come out in
early december to play through for the holidays so
but on like wheels of fortune we didn't
know what the date exactly would be when
when Netflix would want to drop it when they
want to release it obviously I'm sure they have
specific reasons for when they want to to release
movies but I do believe we had the deal for for
wheels of fortune while before we started filming
California Christmas if I'm not mistaken again
a lot of this stuff is I i don't get to deal with
it I don't get the inside information on that but
but yeah so I had two films already
but also esx I believe already had
four films on on Netflix already released
before we started doing the California Christmas
project and that just came
out today yeah not today
when was the production for California
Christmas so we started filming I'm
trying to remember the exact date but it was in
july of 2020 july of 2020 yeah so it was a very
quick turnaround from filming to release it was
it was we were working 24 7 to try and get it
finished through post and delivered because we
had to deliver in I think late october was was
the requirement for delivery if it was gonna
air in in december so it was a very very fast
turnaround so but yeah we started filming in in
january and of course we had to get everything
approved through sag and all of that with the
coveted protocols and and all of that and assuming
it was filmed in california correct yes it was
filmed in california yeah yeah yeah what were
the protocols oh sorry oh yeah I was just gonna
say up in northern california petaluma and sonoma
and those surrounding areas is where we filmed
it was beautiful I felt so lucky and blessed
that number one I was getting to work during this
time because there's so many people who can't work
and that was certainly the case before I got to
film this I hadn't been able to do any physical
production obviously for months and months
oh really sorry to interrupt but you sat you
were at home probably yeah I was able to do some
other work and I had post work to do and things
like that so I still was keeping myself busy but
yeah not not going and physically filming anything
so I felt very lucky to be able to do that
and yes we had to have a very extensive plan
number one just to show to sag and daniel
esperante who was one of the producers on it
he put together this very detailed highly detailed
plan of how we would shoot it how we would keep
everybody safe and a very impressive plan that he
put together and because the movie is a little bit
more self-contained it focuses on these two
actors who happen to be married in real life
that helped with certainly getting things
approved when they got approved because we were
like I mentioned before one of the first features
to to film since this whole thing kind of started
since shutdowns happened and so but yeah it was
very interesting it was a whole different world
as far as filming goes with the covid protocols
number one we were tested like every other day
on the onset the good old nose swabs and
we had more medics on set and also were
temperature checked when we arrived we were
temperature checked before we left every night
just highly diligent we wore face masks of
course if we were in close proximity with the
actors we'd also have the shields so we'd have
mask and shield on and to that effect nobody
was really allowed to go get close to the
actors while they were on set other than the
camera the the camera operators and or dp and
myself the director and maybe the ad first ad
were really the only people that could get
in close proximity with the actors when they
didn't have their masks on so we had to
follow those rules there was also zones
so only a certain amount of people total could
be in any zone at one given time so obviously
set itself or base camp would be the hottest
zone that's where the most people would be
but we tried to keep that all separate and on top
of all of this we had a coveted officer so we had
somebody on set who was overseeing this stuff
and making sure we were keeping socially distant
and that we had our masks up they don't fall
down over our nose and you got a bunch of people
with their noses out he was he's on it matt a
wonderful gentleman who was our covet officer
he was overseeing all of that and making
sure that we were following all the rules and
and he actually did it in a very pleasant way it's
not like he's yelling at people hey your mask is
down no he's very very kind about it but he's
very diligent as well he's on top of it I mean
you really and then the other thing that I forgot
to mention is when the actors are on set no none
of the other departments can come and work with
them on set even including wardrobe and makeup
they would have to leave set first to be able
to be checked like outside things like that as
well like when we're indoors they have to have all
the doors open it's like all of those things to be
very diligent with that stuff and then
like let's say we need to adjust a light
well the actors would have to step offset first
be cleared then the electricians can come in
the the and grip department can come in and they
can fix a light or whatever but the really cool
thing that Brad Rushing our DP thought about
in all of this and I thought it was genius
was they he decided to try and light from outside
as much as possible so bringing in light sources
from outside whether it's backlighting the
actor from like it's sunlight or artificial
sunlight coming through a window or however
it was designed he tried to design a lot of it
coming from outside and the lights that
were inside were remote so we had our
gaffers in our lighting department they could
adjust everything like on ipads and things like
that they were able to dim and do different things
they were able to do a lot without needing to
physically go on set and have to remove the actors
because that of course all takes extra time so I
thought that was pretty genius to to approach it
that way and help us keep our keep our schedules
did did you notice that you would tend to shoot
outside more or no I was just wondering if that
was part of that was part of the design yeah we
did think about that early on with these protocols
try and limit the amount of scenes that need to
be shot indoors and again trying to keep it more
open space and when we did go into like a bedroom
or something like that the crew became very
minimal so again with the covet officer we worked
with him to figure out well how many people can
be upstairs safely and it wasn't about like how
many people can we get in we want to get in as
many as we can there's literally about like what
is a real safe like what's the real number can
we only have five people up here you can have two
people in that room and you can have three people
in this room what I mean so we kind of became that
dance and everybody else has to stay downstairs or
outside so it was that thing so there was a lot
of things to juggle that you don't normally have
to yes they add time the testing adds time to your
like actually takes away time from your shoot day
so you have to account for all of those
things but what I will say is it sounds
daunting it sounds like oh this isn't gonna
work but what I will say is that the the crew
and the new people the the the people dealing
with the covet testing and all of that
we all got into a rhythm first couple days
obviously it's rougher but we all got into a
rhythm and by the end we were all firing on all
cylinders and came everybody came and got their
tests that it just just we came together and we
made it happen and and everybody worked really
hard you had to work hard because the other
the other thing about it is we had less crew
because you can't have too many people so that can
put strain on the different departments like now
they have one less or two less people than they
normally have so again luckily we have a team of
people that really aren't afraid of hard work and
they put in the hard work and they all deserve all
the accolades they can get because they really do
put in a tremendous amount of work and that's why
I keep working with the same team I think because
we share that common goal of all trying to make
something as good as we can especially whether
it's limited resources or time or but they all
just work really really hard and and I think we're
able to accomplish really great things even in the
constraints of working during this time
is the covet officer someone you're hiring
off mandy or one of these sites or is this someone
from the state that's a great question I not
qualified to answer I don't know producers
they handled all of that it is definitely
somebody who's certified within that I don't
even know all the certifications but they're
yeah again I don't really know but I know that
they are very they're certified they're they're
up with all the testing like the latest
like but when we were filming the tests
were changing and we had always the latest
and greatest the best or whatever it was
we started when we first showed up we were doing
blood tests and then it became we were doing the
finger prick stuff at the beginning and then
that morphed into just doing the nose swabs and
then there was different levels of nose swabs and
like it was very interesting but they're always
at the like forefront of whatever it is that's
going to be the best have the highest accuracy
all those things and yeah it was very very
interesting and and that whole team so not
just himself but there's a whole team behind
it they all were wonderful and and obviously
their job was to try and keep us safe and
luckily they did what about crew feed how is
that done because normally it's going to be like
a buffet style that that all changed too yeah so
everything is kind of individually packaged so
and we have caterers and stuff like that that that
craft services was very definitely very different
so everything has to be individually wrapped
you're not you can't go through and thumb
through and touch a bunch of stuff you have to
figure out what you're gonna choose that bag of
fritos now that you touch that bag at your bag
that kind of thing but the probably the biggest
bummer is like I always like to have like fresh
fruit and stuff like that I can't really do that
with these protocols so unfortunately unless you
brought it your own in your own bag which I
did I brought bananas and apples of myself but
yeah that was very different and
again the lunches are very different
you could only have everybody was spaced out like
this the seating area can't have everybody bunched
in and always outside basically and but yeah the
the lunches the meals were all just kind of like
in their own little kind of package individual
portions and packaged and it was fine it it was
just became kind of standard after the first week
everybody was used to it what was the shooting
schedule so the shooting schedule was we usually
do like five on two off type of thing and I think
we had one six day maybe we had two really it was
it was a pretty short schedule that's the other
I think reason why we got approved so
early on is it's a limited amount of days
so that's another thing that they were
looking for like what's the shortest
amount of time you can film this in to to
limit risk of somebody getting infected
so I think we had about 15 days for this shoot all
in like all together which is not a lot of time
to film a movie but again like I said we have a
great crew that helps us accomplish those goals
what was the last day of shooting and
then I'm not sure again what the day for
deliverables was I think in october how much time
I should have to look when the when the last day
of shooting was I think we were just about just
rolled over into august or just right before
august I can't remember exactly the date but yeah
from that time to getting it delivered was was
we usually have twice that amount of time to get
it done however many months that is what is that
basically the end of october is when we had to
deliver if my memory is serving me correctly
and so not only so the good thing was that
the editor had started the process while we
were filming so as we were still filming
as they got footage delivered to them
on hard drives through the mail or couriers
they would get the footage brett hedland
was the the editor he would get it and then
process it and then start cutting the scenes
that was all happening it's offset by obviously a
few days but then once he gets rolling he's just
getting the new footage and continuing
to try and put the pieces together
and by the time we finished shooting it wasn't
far after that that we had the first rough cut
and so and then I once I was finished filming I
got to look at the cuts and start and we break
it up in reels so I started reviewing the reels
giving my notes figuring out what tweaks we can do
or if we're missing a piece how we're going to
solve that and so from the editing just getting
the the picture cut then to the sound design
to the score I mean jamie christopherson who
did our score he had such a small amount of time
to do the score I was blown away with the speed
at which he was able to do it and we had several
original songs in there that he produced along
with caitlyn epperly who is in the movie but she
also sings several original songs for it and while
we were filming he had to be helping create
those like rough versions for her to perform
and lip-sync live to while we were filming it
but that meant those songs had to be done and so
that whole decision that we're going to do these
original songs and from that time to filming
those actual scenes was so short amount of
time I was blown away he was able to do it
and of course they were rough versions of
the song but they still sounded fantastic
and of course they went in they did they
even re-recorded some of the vocals and
did things after the fact but to to get that and
we had to have her go and record her audio for
it and so is this this pretty amazing dance that
happened but but it all worked out beautifully and
then getting people in adr which
was really interesting because
we couldn't bring everybody in like like even for
myself I didn't go into the studio for the adr
I did it from home and so did a lot of our actors
they didn't go to the studio either they were
either abroad or some of them
were in their hotel rooms
doing adr for us we'd either send a
microphone or or somehow get it that way and
it was really really interesting I'd never
experienced anything like that but from from
doing it like that all remote to even the color
correction sessions remotely all doing it over
zoom and now we've all got a much shorter time
to do it it was incredibly challenging but again
everybody just rose to the challenge
and I think that's a lot of of
you know the positive stories out of 2020
that I've seen as people rising to challenges
and it's really to me it's inspirational
obviously I try and look at the glass half
full versus empty that's just my personality but
I really have seen some amazing things come out
of this year of such tragedy and obviously
so many hardships and so much that has gone
wrong in this year I've seen how people have
risen to that challenge and just it's been
inspirational in that respect you think it reminds
you of of how you do things because I could see
you always wanting to problem solve yeah and
fix it and yeah and being successful at that
yeah I think there's probably at some level there
there is me seeing people maybe problem solve in
in the way that makes sense to me so maybe maybe
that's what attracts me to to to seeing that but
yeah I certainly think my again I
go back to my martial arts I think
martial arts itself at least what I have been able
to study and the teachers that I've been lucky
enough to to train under is it's all about problem
solving so it that's 100 of what it is whether
you're fighting an opponent or not or nothing
confrontational because martial arts again from
what the way I've been taught is it goes much
beyond combat there there is that aspect of it
there is self-defense there is the sport element
of it but beyond that it's it's kind of philosophy
and problem solving and it helps you in all walks
of life and I think it certainly has helped me in
filmmaking Shaun how do you feel about you filmed
this movie in july of 2020 it's now mid-december
2020 and today it's the first day it's on Netflix
I have to say it's actually a really good feeling
because a lot of times in filmmaking as you
guys probably well know it can take a long
time from inception to to release in some cases
years and that's certainly been the case for a
lot of my movies some of them are three plus
years before they end up coming out and even
big blockbuster movies they have similar tales
some of them are three plus years other movies
kind of get shelved for a while it could be five
years before they come out so to have something
that you work on within the same year and I
mean even like basically less than six months
kind of go from inception to release it feels
great it's really nice to see something and
and hopefully get a good response with just
today it's released but I've already gotten
really really nice and sweet responses and and
that's just a an amazing feeling and a feeling
that I hope any creator gets to experience at
some point because I also remember every inch of
the set and every second every minute of of that
production because it's still so fresh in my brain
and to go from that to seeing people's
reactions to it this quickly it's a it's a
it's kind of endorphin inducing feeling it feels
really wonderful I had a great morning waking up
to getting some of those messages and with some
of the other movies it's been like three years
it's really hard to remember I
remember certain moments but it's
obviously not the same thing it's it's been
a long time since working on those projects
as a director does Netflix pay you residuals no
and I don't know if that's true for for every film
of course but at least at the level I'm at and
and with these films no there's no residuals
for that and I don't know if that's
the same for actors so I think actors
with sag and all of that obviously there's a much
different probably deal there trying to remember
because there was there was negotiations
for streaming at some point I'm trying to
I'm bad with keeping up on all the latest
information with that but for myself no if
a group of young filmmakers came to you and said
they wanted to make movies only for Netflix what
would you advise them in terms of story production
budget yeah for Netflix that's interesting because
it's kind of this ever moving thing so in in
what trends on there I would say that netflix
at least in my experience or my perception
of it is it is a little bit more
kind of an algorithm-based thing what I'm saying
like it's it's almost like a youtube but not I
mean not the same as youtube but but very much
like what attracts viewership and and things
like that is a little bit more it is constantly
changing so that's a hard one to to figure out
I think Netflix also does things on all spectrums
I mean they have movies that are made at a couple
million they have movies that are made at
100 million so it's really hard to kind of
pinpoint exactly what to say would work to help
you get get it sold onto Netflix other than just
try and make stories that resonate with with an
audience obviously try and make it the it's got
to be of a certain standard certain quality
so I think those are goals to shoot for but
yeah that's a tough one to say I think
there's probably the two spectrums
of of budget levels you've got the
ones that you probably want to keep
under a certain amount because then then the
sale to Netflix makes sense because if you
make it for too much you're never going to
get that amount back if that makes sense
but then on the flip side if you've got big
name actors in it whoever that might be a
will smith or something then obviously those
numbers completely change so you could make a
50 million movie and still sell it and it would
make sense on Netflix but again I think a lot
of those are more of the Netflix originals as
well that they're willing to put in that kind of
that kind of a commitment
for a big big movie like that
I don't really see them going after the more low
low budget stuff like the the sub 1 million dollar
films but again I could be wrong because I just
don't know all the inner inner workings of it um
but they definitely also have parameters in place
for your gear so I'd say first and foremost if
that's really your goal probably the best advice I
could say was find out the specs that they require
because they actually do really require certain
specs like it I believe it has to be shot in 4k
minimum and they literally have gear approved
they have a gear approved list for Netflix like
what you can film on what cameras they approve
and things like that so they actually do have
some technical aspects that you could kind of
lack of a better word screw yourself out
of ever getting a Netflix deal if you don't
meet certain parameters again I don't know
exactly what all those are and they do change
but I do know that there are certain like I
believe the black magic pocket cameras are
actually approved for Netflix so something
on that level which is still affordable
and and to a certain degree are still
at enough quality level to be approved
by Netflix I believe again don't
quote me on any of this but um
but there are certain ones that aren't for
whatever reason it doesn't meet the specs
maybe the color space isn't deep enough
doesn't have enough bits or whatever
so that would be the starting point
like make sure you check with that
kind of stuff and and and make your goals of
filming it to meet those certain parameters
other than that I think they they obviously
stream such a wide variety of things you can see
I've got very kind of family-friendly pg movies
in lady driver and roped that actually were
really successful on Netflix they trended they
were on the popular lists roped I think climbed
as high as like 22 on like most popular
film on Netflix and it's it's a very much
pg family friendly and then you have the
opposite end of the spectrum where you've got the
very gritty dark the stranger things and those
kinds of shows that are extremely successful
so I think they really are open to a variety
of genres and styles of filmmaking so it's
really hard to pinpoint what would work and
what wouldn't work on there but obviously
check the specs that's where I'd start and then
make a good story and and be as creative and get
the best quality that you can and are those specs
available to the public on their website or so
where I've read about it as has been more in like
the like film gear like websites and publications
like that I have seen like hey this camera is
actually meets the meets Netflix approved specs
I personally never have seen a sheet or whatever
that says what those specs are but and I've never
searched it up but I have read about it like I
said in in those like 4kshooter.com or something
like that one of those one of those websites I've
read about the different cameras and if they meet
the spec like this red komodo that just came out
it got Netflix approved so you can use this new
red camera that's it's kind of a much smaller red
and it I believe it shoots 6k so it doesn't do the
8k that the newer reds or the other reds are doing
now like we shot we filmed California Christmas on
a red geminis that are 8k and we we shot with
some vintage lenses though we had these vintage
anamorphic cowas that we shot on on on this 8k
new camera I always I actually really love trying
to meld old and new that's something that really
kind of excites me even to the point that which I
have been known to search ebay for some
vintage style lenses that might not fit on
my cameras but I will figure out a way to adapt
them even with metal files out in the garage I'm
shaving down mounting parts to make them fit
together and I love experimenting with that
kind of stuff so anytime I get that opportunity I
do it this was the second film that I took really
like vintage anamorphic style lenses and put them
match them with the with the newer cameras and
I love the results I think it's just makes for
really interesting imagery and and I just love
anamorphic as well if I had a choice I would film
everything on anamorphic just a quality to it
that that excites me so you feel the older lenses
are are somehow lengthened to a better story and
forgive me I i don't know it's like more character
so the lens the lens itself the older lenses tend
to have more character which can be described
in like maybe the the edges blur a little bit
differently or certainly lens flares are very
different especially with anamorphic and there's
some wonderful new anamorphic lenses I've actually
filmed with them as well and they looked beautiful
but I just happen to really love the
characteristics the way it bends light
is slightly differently slightly different
or again the way it pulls focus maybe to the
center because the edges or maybe the the the
sharpness starts to dissipate towards the edges
which can it in one respect could be a little
bit maybe scary for a filmmaker going oh I want
to make sure the shot's in focus but if you
understand that and know that going in where
the lens might be softer and so you're not
going to frame it that way to where it would
be an issue or you make sure you're paying
attention like oh the top of their heads
may be getting a little too blurry so you reframe
a little bit to make sure they're in the sweet
spot of the lens a lot of the older lenses have
sweet spots so you got to kind of understand and
know that or else you could get yourself in
trouble where the people are out of focus but
but I just love the characteristics of it and
and when you look at certainly the filmmakers
that influenced me the most they almost always
have shot on anamorphic and some of those that
very same models that I've used from the cowas
and the hawks and and even some of the ingenues
some spielberg's and the and the kubricks and
all that use those same same kind of lenses so
that was always kind of a dream of mine was to to
be able to shoot on those someday and then it's
come to fruition on a couple projects I've gotten
to to use some of those vintage lenses which was
exciting for me because I'm kind of a camera nerd
that way I really geek out on all the different
technology and I love new technology but I also
love the old stuff too so again that's where it
comes back to me loving to figure out a way to
marry the two together and that's just always a
a kind of exciting challenge to me and if you
buy those lenses on ebay do you then later sell
them again not really no I kind of keep them I
have some old russian lenses that just do some
really cool bouquet or boca the way it kind
of almost a circular blur to them those are
really cool I've used those actually I used one
of those on California Christmas for a scene
to me they're always like they're tools that you
can use for a certain situation it might be really
perfect for that moment and so I've got those
I've got I just I actually just adapted a a
70s ingenue zoom lens fratello it was a
television lens and it's a gorgeous lens and
I got it for like 150 bucks on ebay and that
lens probably when it came out was 50 60 000
but you couldn't really use it on a modern
camera especially the the mounting wouldn't work
and so what I discovered I had to modify the
mount on it in order to get it to work with
another adapter that would then work on the I
have a blackmagic pocket camera so to get it to
even fit on there I had to modify the the rear
mounting element on it which I took it off the
lens and kind of did everything I needed to do
with it to make it fit and then the other thing
about those lenses and probably why you could get
them I think other people are discovering this now
because I've seen the price of them go up you're
giving away your secrets they're now like 600
ish in that range that I've been seeing but
the lens itself is a eight millimeter to 112
millimeter zoom which is a pretty decent
zoom but it's the size of of the the back
glass is too small for a modern camera like a
like a black magic what happens when you put
that lens on there you have a crazy vignette so
you basically see the circle of the back element
so that you're only seeing and everything else
is black and you've got this little circle
and that's the reason why most people wouldn't
buy that lens and you can get them for the price
that you can get them but on certain versions
of those lenses they had built-in doublers
so basically there's a magnifier on the back end
of the lens that you can flip and what the purpose
of it originally was for those lenses is it made
them twice the focal length so you could then
on the just a flip of a switch you could double
your focal length you could go from a 100 to a
200 millimeter zoom and there's all sorts of cool
things you can do with that what I discovered is
that you could take that same lens and put the
doubler on it and now it fills the full frame of
my camera so I don't have an 8 to 112 millimeter
I actually have a 14 to 220 millimeter lens which
is still a great focal length for me to have on
my camera I mean that's as wide as i'll ever need
it and that's almost as tight as i'll ever need
it and so that was the experiment of wanting to
make that lens work and figure out how to adapt it
to get it to work on my camera and it worked it's
it's really pretty incredible and in fact the
black magic is there's a crop factor or like a
on that so effectively what my camera is is
I think it's a 22 millimeter to 400 and like
450 millimeter zoom and it looks beautiful
I did a bunch of test footage with it and
again it has those old characteristics that
I love looks like you're shooting something
in the 60s or 70s and cost me 150 bucks so there
you go and I will use it on a project I guarantee
somewhere somehow i'll end up using that lens for
something so you keep them safely stored away yeah
yeah and I bring it with me on my project so yeah
so it was so interesting about that anjanu is that
it's a it's a french-made lens and the style of
a mount that it had was I think it was called the
b3 like a bayonet 3. and Japanese lenses made it
American all that stuff they all had this b3 mount
well I was able to find online b3 adapters to
micro four thirds so great here we go I can
I can just buy this adapter and it'll work no it
didn't work there was a piece on that back element
that on that back mount element on the ingenu
that was several millimeters deeper than it was
on like the canons of the same era or the
other ones that that adapter would work on
did not work on mine so I looked I had to really
like break it down like what is stopping this
adapter from mounting correctly I figured out
which pieces it was and then I'm like okay
so how do I get this this piece luckily it was
aluminum so it was fairly soft that mounting piece
so I was able to take metal files like I said
get it down to the right level which actually
took a long time longer than I was expecting and
then I went with some finer sanding materials
and and got it to be smooth and then I like
finished it so that it was wouldn't affect
the adapter at all and then it worked mounted on
there and and I didn't know if that would change
your rear focus element I was a little bit
worried that maybe that would affect it
to where this adapter is made for a certain
thing and your back glass needs to be a certain
distance from your sensor in order for it to
work so I wasn't sure by filing this piece down
if I would was a risk I was like I could be
possibly ruining this at this mount for my lens
and it might not it might not work because it'll
just be a few millimeters different but luckily
it actually worked right out of the gate as soon
as I mounted it I was able to focus all the way
through and those old the other cool thing
about those old lenses is they have a back
element adjuster so it's basically like a screw
a nut that you undo and you can then move and it
moves the distance from that back glass so you can
really dial it in you can dial them in to to be
I'm trying to remember the term but it's basically
at your widest focal distance you're in focus and
when you zoom in through the whole thing you're
in focus and only certain lenses can do that
and new lenses don't a lot of them don't do
that or they're like sixty thousand dollars
like I said that lens will do this but your two
thousand dollar canon can't do that what I mean
so having this lens that has that ability is
pretty darn cool and I was able to dial that
all in I was I was I was actually really surprised
that one worked to be honest but I then bought two
more of that style lenses to try and experiment
one I failed one I can't get it to adapt correctly
but the other one I was it was a canon one was a
fujinon I couldn't get the fujinon to work right
but the canon I was able to to get to work and I
just used that one on a commercial shoot not that
long ago and it worked great and again that was a
similar focal length so right now it's like a 28
to 480 millimeter zoom if you want to know those
are the old eng lenses okay so those are old like
60s 70s 80s really like 70s is probably where most
of these are from but they're eng lenses so like
beretta and shows like that like yeah yeah yeah
and you can probably find that most of them are
like fujinon and canon like on ebay and stuff and
they're the I'm trying to think if it's there the
two-thirds inch eng lenses is what I'm talking
about and they need to have that built-in doubler
so it's like a two times focal length piece on it
and they look really funky they come off the back
of the lines that's how you can usually tell
they're on there but in the description always
make sure you get one because if you get one that
doesn't have that doubler and you try and put it
on a modern camera most of them it will again like
I said you'll just have that big vignette where
it's not really usable but once you have that
the doubler that's built in onto them that
you can never use it really without it on so you
just have to live with this is my new focal length
is is the double of this lens what I mean so
because you said it gets too close to the sensor
it's not that it gets too close to the sensor
it's just that the back element is too small
to cover the full width of your sensor so but
what happens is when that with those built-in
doublers is it's a piece of glass that basically
if this is the back of the lens if this is your
piece of glass this this magnifier comes on top
of it and it is bigger than that piece and that
magnifica magnification it creates the image to be
big enough to cover your your whole lens or your
whole I'm sorry sensor so you don't you no longer
have those vignette on your on your thing so
yeah it's pretty cool pretty cool little little
trick I'm not the only one who's discovered it
either there's there's other people who have
who have experimented with it but definitely
it's not like a common thing but I always
love that stuff like I said I've taken old
still camera lenses I've got some zeiss lenses
from the from the 50s and 60s that I've adapted
from exact amounts which is a really
interesting mount luckily I was able
to find some people that have made pieces to
to that can adapt that to like cannon mount
and and then I take the cannon mount and adapt
that to the micro four thirds or whatever the the
different challenges are or different camera that
we might be putting it on but I've gotten some
great those the old zeiss's are usually at least a
couple hundred dollars but to me if you can find a
clean one that doesn't have a bunch of scratches
on the lens or a bunch of fungus on the lens
they're still they're really great pieces
of glass I have a 25 millimeter zeiss
carl zeiss lens from the 50s that's
incredible it's tack sharp still today and
just a really really nice piece of glass that I
got for a couple hundred dollars where anything
modern would cost you several thousand at least
for that same focal length and and quality
how do you protect it from fungus
do you keep it away from moisture
yeah that the funny thing about
fungus is that it actually uh
it's hard to to say why some
lenses get it and some don't
but it is probably it has to do with
moisture and and how sealed they are
most of the time though fungus really won't affect
your image too much it affects how light comes in
to the lens and will like bend like like kind of
the flares so sometimes even a little fungus is
kind of cool on an old lens in my opinion now
if it's right in the dead center of your lens
maybe that then becomes annoying but if it's just
around the edges again it could give you some of
those qualities that I actually even like so
I won't necessarily turn down a lens on ebay
if it's got a little fungus on it just depends
on where it is but things like scratches and
things that really will kind of affect the image
then obviously you got to stay away from that but
yeah I mean it depends on what project
you're doing if you need something super
clean and you want it to look tack sharp like
that then those lenses won't be for you but
if you're trying to do something that has
a little bit more of that style to it then
I say go for it experiment with it and and see
what you can do because to me that's that's what
will set your project apart make it make it feel a
little different how would if a lens has fungus on
it if you're seeing it on some site that's selling
well I always ask those questions and most people
that I've discovered they will they'll list what's
wrong with the lens and stuff like that so most
of them will say no clean glass no scratches
fungus free they'll say something like that
or they'll talk about the blades the blades
aren't oily because a lot of times the lenses
if the like they'll have like a a leak in the
the it'll affect how the shutter and the aperture
works not the shutter but the the aperture itself
so they'll list like what's you know you just
have to read the details then ask questions if
you and i'll ask that a lot of times i'll ask
you know is it does it have this
or does it have that to clarify
and again like I said sometimes I might be okay
with it they go is there fungus is it like all
over the the lens or is it like just on the edges
and and I might still buy it if it has it if it
if that's what I'm going for in that
moment and if the price is right
Shaun I'm hoping we can go to page one of
your script for a California Christmas and
I'm curious what you like about the opening scene
of the movie which is page one of course yeah so
the opening is obviously it's meant to establish
joseph's character played by josh wickard
and he's kind of living this playboy lifestyle big
city wealthy obviously he's got someone in bed and
he's young and he's kind of using his his
obviously his status to kind of live carefree
in that way so basically the point of it is to set
up his character and and for his arc throughout
the story because obviously he needs to grow he's
not the best of guys at this point so it's really
I think it helps illustrate that point it sets
up who he is and the journey he's gonna have to
go on whether he likes it or not is basically is
is the idea obviously you won't know all of that
while seeing this first scene but it sets it up
of who he is and where he is at at this point in
his life and he's not a total jerk he offers to
buy the woman room service so you got to give him
some props but so yeah yeah again I think those
little details is that we we don't want people to
just completely hate him right off the bat right
and we did have some other things early in early
versions and stuff that we're like yeah that might
make him too much of a jerk certainly there's an
argument there that he's still a jerk but what
I'm saying like he has to have some underlying
qualities and redeemable pieces that that you
want to see him go on a journey of growth and
self-growth and and becoming hopefully a
better person so before we meet joseph the
main character we have this aerial shot can we
talk about the establishing image yes the very
first shot is kind of coming up off the off
the water and revealing san francisco which is
that's where he is and where his family business
is so kind of just establishing that whole the
bay area and the big city and the in the the
hustle and bustle of city life because it
is a obviously stark contrast to the ranch that he
later goes to and ends up spending a lot of time
and we also did some interesting things in color
there so the city life has has a little bit cooler
of tones to them and when we go to the ranch
everything becomes a little bit warmer and and
earthier in the tones so that's like
a little kind of little details that
we pay attention to when we're making it
probably most people will never notice it
but even with that opening shot we wanted the
color palette of it to be feel cooler in tone
versus the later part of the movie and also too
he leaves kind of like one woman in a hotel room
and then as he leaves he kind of flirts with
a desk clerk or something and yeah you see her
sort of fun not not unprofessionally but you
so it already sets him up to be sort of this
casanova type correct yes yeah he's definitely got
that air about him and and you get the sense that
he doesn't hear know a lot she doesn't hear no
a lot it's that hashtag best life thing right
he's living his best life but anyways obviously
there's more to it than that and and at his core
he's he's searching for more sure sure what do
you think the hook is of the first page that makes
people want to keep reading it goes beyond just
the first page I guess but the hook of the first
page is is is really the the kind of setting
and the character like for me when I read it
I wanted to know more about him so it's really
like why is he this way like what makes him
and especially kind because he's kind of outright
just turns the girl down for a second date like
right there makes you go well that's audacious
like what like what is his story so hopefully
that's the hook that was for me when I read it
because I didn't write this Lauren Swickard didn't
and when I was sent it that's what grabbed
me right away and I think she says kind of
like i'll call you or whatever and she says no
you want yeah exactly that little piece right
there I'm like okay yeah and and the fact that he
can get away with that I think there's probably
plenty of people go well I wouldn't be able to get
away with that or you know those kinds of things
it makes it intriguing and and and of course the
you see that the relationship walking through the
hotel lobby the people like him and he's he's
got that thing about him his charm is charisma
always makes it more interesting and I think even
in the back of my head I'm was even initially even
right away thinking oh he's gonna have some
lessons to learn what I mean like there's
he's probably gonna have to go on a journey
and sorry he's brought in to be and I hope
this isn't spoiler to be like a honey plot to
kind of like infiltrate and and seduce someone
that he needs a signature from so basically his
his company and his mother who runs the company
they haven't been able to get this the owners
of this ranch to sell which they need to build
a shipping facility for their corporation
their business and so his mom decides that
her son basically doesn't really do
anything he's got a title and works
at the company but what does he actually do
so she recognized he has a certain skill and
and it is a younger woman who owns the ranch and
so she says let's put your actual skills to use
go out there and get this girl to sell get this
woman young woman to sell and so I think he thinks
he's going to be able to waltz in there and and
get his way and and get the the the yes that he
always hears and and I can say it doesn't go
as as he had planned sure and his ark falls
there's some case of missing missing identity
as well or misidentity that that not missing a
misidentity that that happens for him as well
in there that kind of starts him down a totally
different journey that that he thought he was
going to be going on so looking back on it now
what mistakes do you think were there in the first
page or was this the actual shooting script and
there were no mistakes oh well this yeah this is
definitely not the the first version of the script
for sure so this is this is closer to the shooting
I can't remember if what I sent you is the actual
shooting shooting one and gosh it's hard to
remember if if there was I think there there was
more time taken in in earlier drafts which I think
it took too long to get to those pieces and it
is of course not even just the first page but but
that was part of it so I think it got more refined
and kind of picked the moments that actually
mattered to to convey the the message that we're
trying to convey is this still the opening of the
movie yes this is still the opening of the movie
right so yeah it it stayed and obviously I think
it's important again because we have to establish
our our character's journey his character so
joseph and also cali they both have their journeys
and they kind of their journeys intersect
and that's what they they help each other
on their journey so that's kind of the that's the
age-old kind of love twist there their their their
journeys intersect and and of course they need
each other to to kind of complete their journey
the film American Fighter you're the co-writer
Shaun is that right yes I co-wrote it and directed
it oh great okay and it has martial arts elements
to it yep oh yeah yep there's martial arts
so definitely drew from some of that experience
and it's interesting because it takes place in
1981 so it's kind of pre-mma in that whole thing
so it deals with kind of illegal underground
fighting so certainly martial arts involved
but there's also this kind of street fighting
brawling thing that happens as well and and in
wrestling and so it integrates a lot of different
fighting styles if we take a look at the first
page for the screenplay that you co-wrote
American Fighter our protagonist is raza and
you see kind of his life it seems like it jumps
back to different parts can you talk about that
yeah so the main character is actually Ali he
the opening of the film which which I felt was
was important was to kind of tell this story
kind of jumping back and forth and it opens with
him in kind of the fight of his life the movie
starts with this you see some images some flashes
and pieces of this fight and where he's kind of
going to be at the lowest point as well and then
we take a step back and the film is then going to
lead up to that moment again and the reason for
that was it wasn't originally written that way
this was the later and then to the shooting
draft we decided that it was important to have
show that element right away number one to kind of
it's that big impactful start like get audiences
interested and curious like wait a minute why is
this happening why are these two people fighting
and there's a huge crowd around them and and
what is it all about we see our hero fall right
like right in this the end of this beginning
fight he gets almost knocked unconscious and so
we go from there to him waking up in his college
dorm room and that's several weeks earlier or
months earlier he's worried about his his family's
supposed to be flying because he's from Iran
and he's worried about and this is 1981 so the
setting is the Iraq Iran war had just started
and it was a terrible time in that area and
just like two years earlier was the Iran
hostage crisis that happened and so in America at
that time it was not a great time to be Iranian
and so he had to face those kinds of issues
but so he wakes up this college dorm room
he's got a roommate who's a good friend and
but he's really afraid for his parents he wants
them to make it over from Iran safely to the u.s
and so his roommates kind of assure him that he's
gonna be fine and they've got wrestling practice
and so the idea the concept is he is there for
like a wrestling scholarship and that's
part of what helped get him out of Iran
iran I should say not Iran but Iran helped get
him out of Iran because of his wrestling prowess
and so he's now trying to help his parents get
over because his mom is sick she has cancer
and so he's trying to get her to to some more
western medicine and that's kind of what jumps off
the the story so in the first page if I
remember correctly there's is like a sort
of these different flashes so he's getting beat
up then you see like a happy moment where he's
running and saying mom I'm coming to America
look at the letter or something there's a
flash of the picture of the ayatollah and then
there's the mother being hooked up to tubes
so all these like sort of things are coming at
you yeah that's when he gets knocked unconscious
he flashes back to his childhood when he was
back in Iran and he's kind of flashing to the
moment that he found out that his mother
that something was wrong with his mom
so that's kind of that's what's happening there
he's not running excited that he's going to
to America what's happening is actually his
father is telling him he's going to send him
there because he'll be safer oh okay sorry so he's
going to go live with his uncle in America and
he's actually disappointed like he's he's scared
about this prospect of having to leave his family
but they recognize that he has the opportunity
there he's obviously really good at wrestling and
that can that's what's creating this opportunity
for him to get out of the really bad situation
that was happening at that time and so it's almost
a nightmare of what he's experiencing and that
leads him into waking up in his dorm room and so
yes he hears a new news broadcast you see that's
it's maybe a little bit different in the actual
film versus what's on the page but basically
there's news broadcasts happening talking about
the events that are that are happening during
that time and that kind of crosses with what his
father is telling him about I need to send you
to America and and then him rushing to see his
mother and I always had this like kind of haunting
image of following him kind of in a a slower
motion as he's making his way down this hallway
to this door that's cracked open and as he as he
pushes the door open he sees his mother and she
looks at him smiling and as she tries to stand
up to talk to him she collapses and that's the
the terror he's he's having in that moment
and it's actually based on something that
really happened to me so that was that was a
moment directly ripped from my own childhood
and my mother is still here so i'll preface it
that way but she had an aneurysm so it wasn't
cancer but it was an aneurysm and she collapsed
in a very similar way and it was that terrifying
and I had my own kind of fevered nightmares for
years and years about it and so that's a little
piece of me that made it into the the script
there that's melded with other kind of memories
from Ali as well Ali Afshar because he produced
it and this character is actually based on him
now this story has some real elements but other
ones are we fabricated for for for the movie but
the character himself is based on Ali and his
because he's also a wrestler and all of that stuff
and he did come over from Iran and and all that
have some similar experiences there so you really
see the stakes are high so it's not just he's
being pulled from his homeland leaving his family
there's government turmoil his mother is sick so
everything's kind of thrown in that first page
yep all stakes are like what he's dealing with
right there okay yeah okay did page one did it
evolve did it change was it definitely did yeah
it definitely evolved and at first we didn't see
that fight happening and right away it did always
kind of start with that dream so that was there
from the beginning but yeah it evolved there
was many many different drafts of it and
we experimented with different ways to open
it and ultimately that's what we settled on
was kind of yeah throwing all the all the and
I there is a kind of a funny story to as to why
we ended up going that direction and within the
movie because the time it was it was the summer
what was the school year after the summer
that star wars empire strikes back came out
and so within that script that was all the rage
at the time like everybody was talking about
especially obviously the first star wars was
such a huge success and then this follow up
with yoda and everything and the controversial
ending of empire strikes back sorry spoilers but
Darth Vader is Luke's father that's like
all anybody talked about at that time and
so we worked that into the script I'm a huge
star wars nerd myself I love star wars and so
a lot of that my personality was coming out
through the script in that way too so we have
ali's roommates characters really into star
wars and he can't believe that Ali has never
seen star wars so that is a running joke through
the whole script and he's doing yoda impressions
very terribly by the way but doing them
nonetheless and and so I thought that
was a really fun thing to to help set the
tone and time place that this movie was set
but the other thing that I thought about was
looking at great movies like that like the
original star wars how does it open it opens with
such a bang I mean it's just right off the bat
action is happening spaceships are flying
overhead lasers are going you just get all
this all the stakes are set right there and so
that influenced how the opening pages of our movie
happened it was like obviously we don't
have spaceships and all that fun stuff but
we want to throw it in your face right away
like start it with a bang and hopefully get
the audience hooked right there right from
the first flash you see on screen and like
whoa what's happening oh my gosh it's a fight
and oh look at this kick and this punch and oh
he's oh no he's he's down already is is directly
kind of influenced from star wars and like how
the rebels immediately their ship gets captured by
the bad guys and all hope looks lost right away so
yeah with American Fighter are we establishing
I'm sorry is it reza is it is he is he the main
character or not Ali oh sorry for some reason I
think yeah I may have sent you I may have sent you
a a draft that had the wrong name like okay we
did play with it not being ally at one point
so that's probably the draft you got no problem I
was searching for those drafts and I couldn't find
because again on a different computer three years
ago so I think I must have sent you the wrong one
on accident in page one of American Fighter
are we establishing ali's kind of personality
or we're just more seeing the stakes that he's
against I think yeah it's more about the stakes
that he's against because in the first page we
don't get to see maybe a ton of his personality
but that does come out right kind of in this
in the the subsequent pages you get to know
him a little bit more and and comes out in some of
the playful banter with him and his roommate and
and but the the story does get very serious
very quick for Ali so unfortunately he doesn't
get a lot of lighthearted time in this in this
particular film is this first page still the
opening of the movie more or less yeah there was
some tweaks that that and some stylistic choices
that we played with but it's not exactly
but yeah there's a lot of it is still there
so what was the log line for American Fighter did
you or like if you were going to do your elevator
pitch what was it sort of oh my gosh it's been
so long fight club meets wrestlers yeah it's
it's it's it's it really is it's like got equal
parts rocky and and karate kid I mean those are
those it's got a lot of heart and and blood sport
I don't know how many people know bloodsport but
it's it's kind of an amalgamation of all those
things but again like I said the the heart and
the reason why he fights is to try and save
his mother so that's kind of at the core of it
and that kind of sets it apart from those movies
in a way but yeah it's the it's the journey
for this character ally like how far is he willing
to go for for love for family and it's a love
story about his there is a love interest in it and
played by the awesome alison page she's amazing
but the the core of the love story is actually
that for his his mother and he's willing to do
anything to help save her and including fighting
in underground bare-knuckle brawls putting his
life at risk if it means he can save her because
the story is is actually very tragic his father is
killed when they try and leave the country and it
has to deal with the with the the the events that
were going on at that time so how many drafts
did you have of the script oh my gosh lots lots
probably too many to count like official drafts we
go through the different colors once we we started
pre-production probably a good six or seven or
something like that that's like from initial
like breaking maybe more like five but yeah all
in at least a dozen yeah at least probably more.